to me the number one thing at this age
that you have to do is take risks early
on because when you get older you regret
not taking risks in your 20s is when you
take your biggest risks because when
you're 40 60 80 you'll regret if you
don't you're going to be 77 and you're
going to say why the garyvee told
me 20 50 years ago I should have
listened because it will kill you much
more than losing the biggest thing that
kids worry about is lose
that's why they don't take risks because
they don't want to lose in front of each
other in front of their parents it's the
number one reason I make content I'm
trying to get people to be less scarce
so you lost right